Sonic is back with a new friend and a new
foe in "Sonic the Hedgehog 2" – and a familiar
voice is bringing the blue blur's new friend
Tails to life on the big screen.
Here's everything else you need to know before
you see "Sonic the Hedgehog 2."
"Let's do this."
Even after it was almost derailed by a set
of eerily human-looking teeth, the film adaptation
of Sega's beloved mascot was a hit both with
fans of the games and at the box office, earning
nearly $320 million worldwide.
Although critics felt there was some room
for improvement, the zippy design of Sonic
himself and the likable cast of human characters
were enough to have the film declared the
rare successful video game adaptation.
Just three months after the release of the
first movie, Variety confirmed that "Sonic
the Hedgehog 2" was officially on the way,
with director Jeff Fowler and screenwriters
Pat Casey and Josh Miller all returning.
In the first film, we're introduced to Sonic,
an alien hedgehog who uses a dimension-bending
ring to travel to earth.
Once there, he's pursued by the evil Dr. Robotnik,
who wants to harness Sonic's supersonic speed
for use in his robotics experiments.
Sonic teams up with Sheriff Tom and his wife
Maddie in order to evade Dr. Robotnik's increasingly
menacing attempts to capture the hedgehog.
"Sonic the Hedgehog" was enjoyable and did
justice to the games, but it also left lots
of room to go bigger and better with another
installment.
Now that we know one is on the way, let's
dig into the details of what we know about
the release date, cast, and plot of the upcoming
"Sonic the Hedgehog 2."
When Paramount made the announcement about
the sequel, it was just that: news and not
much else.
However, in late July 2020, the studio revealed
the official release date for "Sonic the Hedgehog
2."
Ben Schwartz, who voices the speedy little
hedgehog, posted to his Twitter account a
video of himself confirming the news.
The video simply featured Schwartz strolling
beside massive promotional posters for "Sonic
the Hedgehog" while awkwardly explaining what
he was seeing.
The caption of the video is where the actor
made things crystal clear: "SONIC 2 IS OFFICIALLY
COMING 2 THEATERS 4/8/22!!"
One of the biggest strengths of the first
"Sonic the Hedgehog" was its cast.
Ben Schwartz, best known for "Parks and Recreation"
and "The Afterparty," and an avowed fan of
the original Sonic games, gave an energetic
vocal performance as the titular hedgehog.
Jim Carrey was delightfully unhinged as the
villainous Dr. Robotnik, while James Marsden
and Tika Sumpter provided the right balance
of humor and heart as Sonic's unassuming human
allies.
All four actors will reprise their roles in
"Sonic the Hedgehog 2.
Colleen O'Shaughnessy, who voiced Tails in
the Sonic games, performed the character's
dialogue in a brief, post-credits sequence.
That set up Tails to be a much more prominent
part of the next film, and O'Shaughnessy will
return.
There are two new big names in the cast of
"Sonic the Hedgehog 2."
In June 2021, Shemar Moore, well known for
his work on CBS procedurals "Criminal Minds"
and "S.W.A.T.," posted to Instagram a picture
of himself on the "Sonic 2" set with the other
primary members of the human cast.
He announced his casting, but didn't reveal
any details about his character.
However, Moore briefly appears in a scene
in the third "Sonic the Hedgehog 2" trailer.
In August 2021, Variety reported that Emmy-and-Oscar-nominated
superstar Idris Elba had joined "Sonic the
Hedgehog 2" as the voice of Knuckles, a Sonic
adversary-turned-ally in the '90s Sega games.
During the 2021 Game Awards, "Sonic the Hedgehog
2" voice actor Ben Schwartz introduced the
first trailer for the film, with a second
teaser arriving in time for the 2022 Super
Bowl.
Both clips revealed a few details about the
plot of the highly anticipated sequel.
After Sonic blasted away Dr. Robotnik to a
mushroom planet in the first film, he was
determined to escape his prison and return
to Earth.
As revealed in the third trailer, which hit
the internet on March 14th, Dr. Robotnik returns
to wreak more havoc, and he's in possession
of a giant green emerald, which he proclaims
to be "the source of ultimate power."
Sonic, after crashing through a ring portal
on a pile of snow, rudely interrupting a Hawaiian
destination wedding, announces his intention
to stop his persistent nemesis — or otherwise,
"the world is doomed."
Neither side is alone in their quest this
time.
Dr. Robotik has brought along the destructive
and nefarious echidna Knuckles, while Sonic
has Tails fighting in his corner.
Overall, the "Sonic" sequel looks like it
has much more in common with the games that
inspired the movie, with familiar faces on
a new adventure hopefully everyone will love.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.